يعني لم يغب كورونا حتى بدانا نقلق من
فيروس جديد وهو مارج هذا القلق المتزايد
يغذيه مشاهدينا تفشي هذا الفيروس فيروس
مارفبورغ في تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه في
مشهد طبعا شبهه خبراء باعاده تجربه كورونا
الكارثيه فالهاجس من اتساع رقعه الفيروس
وتحوله الى جائحه عالميه بدا بالانتشار
وما يصحبه من عزل المحتمل لدول شرق وغرب
افريقيا منظمه الصحه العالميه حذرت من
تفشي الفيروس بالدولتين الافريقيتين
اللتين سجلتا 8 الى ثلاثه عشره اصابه في
كل دوله معظمهم طبعا لقوا حتفهم للاسف
وعلى اثره بدا الدول العالم باتخاذ
اجراءات السلامه والاحتياطات اللازمه دول
الخليجيه منعت رعاياها من السفر الى هاتين
الدولتين فيما اكتفت بل اكتفت دول اخرى
بالتحذير هو من عائله الفيروس المسبب لحمى
ايبولا النزفيه هو طبعا شديد العدوى يتسبب
بارتفاع الحراره والصداع الحاد والالام
العضليه
ومعدلات وفيات عاليه بين المصابين اما طرق
انتقاله فهي كالتالي ينتقل للبشر من
خفافيش الفاكهه وايضا من الاتصال المباشر
بالسوائل الجسديه للمصابين والاسطح
والمواد الملوثه بتلك الوسائل بل السوائل